Cosmic Stardust
Midnight Magic
Botanical Bliss yeah I could hear some
Bliss up in here
okay girl you're fine they're fine just
keep your distance
[ __ ] about anything with this [ __ ] on
well
I guess it's time to start getting back
everyone cover your nose and mouth and
just stay calm stay the [ __ ] come
I forgot my sanitizer oh I need
sanitizer quick who's got some goddamn
sanitizer
it's just my allergies
you know pollen
allergies
damn girl
Panda Minister really [ __ ] you up huh
yeah it [ __ ] me up
but I don't think I'm doing too much I'm
just being honest
there goes another Cesspool of germs oh
that's not kid sweat no thank you
I'm hella bacteria uh-uh not the one
I know I look like I'm training for the
[ __ ] parkour Olympics out here but
see you and then a nice 37 000 punch in
the face how are you gonna charge me 600
for a damn IV bag that [ __ ] is just salt
water and plastic
am I crazy avoiding people I don't know
this might be the same [ __ ] I have ever
done
[Music]
and remember to follow your breath and
now let's move into vrikshasana tree
pose
[Music]
I don't know Sasha I feel like my tree
pose feels more like a twig
you're doing great Ruby just stay
present and trust your body
now let's move into Vera bhadrasana
Warrior Two
uh just just leave it at the door please
leave it leave it at the door
that thank you
my bad I'm so sorry okay
where were we
uh
checking out my awesome warrior pose
because I literally put a piece of tape
on the wall over there like you said and
just
helping me with my balance
tofu no stop
stop no no
tofu no no
don't don't worry he'll he'll stop
eventually
stop for food stop
[Music]
um hey uh
hey Sasha
um
how long are you going to only be doing
online classes
because I'm I'm a bit zoomed the [ __ ]
out and it's really hard to get my
Namaste on with the background of your
life going on you know
I know
trust me I hate this [ __ ] too I'm just
what is it are you scared of getting the
runner the bills
I'm scared of the bills oh I mean I
already got covered last year and my
weak ass Insurance didn't even cover the
ride to the damn Hospital thanks now I'm
in so much debt
I don't even know how to move
damn I'm really sorry to hear all of
that
um
because you're all vaxxed right yeah but
the variants and the vaccine wearing off
and [ __ ] I'm scared of spraining my
ankle and having to pay for a [ __ ]
x-ray
it's gonna be all right girl
why don't you do a GoFundMe page
remember Paula I think just recently she
raised like 15K for her little
Chihuahuas chemo [ __ ] that dog is
healthier than me now
so [ __ ] up
okay we only we only have a little time
left let me refocus before I lose my one
last client
let's close out with some silent
meditation
no matter how hard life gets
we can always come back to our balance
by coming back to our breath
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
no no I I know who it is no I haven't
miraculously hit the lottery since you
called way back when three whole days
ago but thanks for checking in yet again
okay you might want to hit the meme girl
ma'am I'm
you're just doing your job but everybody
acts like this is [ __ ] normal CEOs
making billions of dollars off of people
getting sick and then and then and then
chasing me down and trying to ruin my
life y'all are worse than the mob
you're definitely kill him I'm a goddamn
yoga teacher
yoga means Union but this is not the
union I need I need benefits I need
protection
I need a government that gives a [ __ ]
about me I'm I'm
I'm just gonna sign off now all I have
is I'll see you next week is this yoga
mat
this candle
this this blender that I make my
wheatgrass smoothies in I don't even
like wheatgrass
but I drink it and that's my health
insurance in the richest [ __ ] country
in the world
nah
it's America
ah
[ __ ]
Ruby
okay
okay
deep breath in
listen
[Music]
[Music]